[Music]
our main story tonight concerns
chemicals the substances that along with
spaghetti heineken and human arms should
never be kept in a vat in your
neighbor's garage
specifically we'll be talking about a
particular class of chemicals tonight
called pifas which stand for per and
polyfluoroalkyl substances they go by a
wide variety of chemical names like all
of these and they are used by
recognizable brands like gore-tex and
teflon among many many others but the
main thing they have in common is that
they make surfaces that don't get stuff
stuck to them which is something a lot
of us care about although arguably some
more than others
missy
if you saute scallops in a non-stick pan
they won't stick that's why it's called
nonstick
i don't know what nonstick means it
takes a sweetheart but me
you know
as tempted as i am to mock gordon ramsay
as a british person who's also
inexplicably made a career of shrieking
obscenities and americans and not
understanding texas game has no choice
but to recognize game
and while ice cream you scream he
screams we all scream for non-stick
pants there's just two big problems here
first these chemicals have been linked
to a massive array of health issues high
exposures to these two major p-files
alone have been linked to high
cholesterol ulcerative colitis
pregnancy-induced hypertension thyroid
disease testicular and kidney cancer and
decreased response to vaccines which is
clearly terrible although also shouldn't
really be that surprising to you things
the original name for this show was that
thing you like is bad with saudi long
legs
and second p-files are what's known as
forever chemicals studies have estimated
they have lifetimes in the thousands of
years and that combination of toxicity
and longevity is a real problem as one
chemical engineer tried to explain to
congress a few years back
it doesn't go away this is a man-made
chemical we just pass the baton to our
generations of kids
in fact
if you were to incinerate and cremate me
i would technically be a fluorochemical
hazardous source
the teflon mesh that's used in my hernia
produces a very toxic gas and decomposes
to something called devil's piss which
is hydrofluoric acid
you can't kill this beast
you can only control it yeah that
doesn't sound great does it also it is
hard to believe there's something called
devil's piss that isn't gordon ramsay's
very real line of alcoholic sparkling
water hell seltzer which you could
apparently get in flavours such as mean
green berry inferno knicker twist and
that's forked held seltzer for people
who hate water and themselves
but the thing is that man is absolutely
right to an extent that you may not
currently realize the world is basically
soaked in the devil's piss right now and
not in a remotely hot way so tonight we
thought we'd take a look at just how bad
these substances are how long some of
their major manufacturers knew about it
and how hard this will all be to fix and
let's start by looking one of the most
ubiquitous pfas pfoa also known as c8
because of its eight carbon molecules 3m
started selling c8 back in 1951 to the
chemical giant dupont which then used it
to make teflon which it marketed through
ads like this
i used to be a slave to scraping and
scrubbing pots and pans but i've been
liberated by teflon food doesn't stick
to teflon like it does to other things
see
okay i used to be a slave is just not
something that should be coming out of a
white child's face unless it's pinocchio
after he becomes a real boy and even
then he's still not really free is he
he's a slave to society in a prison of
his own mind just like the rest of us
your nose might not be growing anymore
in yawkey but make no mistake you are
lying to yourself
but the thing is by the time that ad
aired 3m and dupont already knew that
these chemicals accumulated in humans
and animals that they didn't degrade in
the environment and that they could
increase the size of the liver in rats
rabbits and dogs so the warning signs
were very much there before they had a
white child slave claimed that teflon
liberated her from the back breaking
labour of scraping muffin trays
and in the decades that followed they
learned even more in 1981 3m found
ingestion of pfas caused birth defects
in rats and when they told dupont about
this and dupont then tested the children
of employees in their teflon division
they found that of seven births two had
eye defects information interestingly
dupont did not make public and by 1991
it had gotten unambiguous warnings that
it then spectacularly ignored
3m told dupont that under no
circumstances should you put it in
waterways it's right there in the
document don't put this in the waterways
but at the end of the day they start
dumping so much c8 ends in the water
that they at one point lose track of how
much they've actually put out there
wow
harmful chemicals are just not something
you should lose track of they're not
your car keys or your middle child oh oh
i'm sorry i lose him in a supermarket
one time and suddenly i'm a bad parent
calm down it's not like he was gonna run
out of food but wait it gets even worse
two years after that in 1993 a dupont
memo shows that for the first time they
had a viable candidate to replace c8 one
that appeared to be less toxic and
stayed in the body for a much shorter
duration of time but the company decided
against it because the risk was too
great specifically the risks of their
bottom line and the fact that teflon
products were worth roughly a billion
dollars in annual revenue to them
proving once overall corporations truly
are people specifically sociopaths and
yet despite knowing all of that dupont
kept pushing for teflon to be used in
more and more places and in this ad from
1994 they basically present it as being
wizardry
chemistry is the is the practice of
magic
people think of teflon they think of
frying pans teflon is not one thing
putting teflon on a surface will stop
bugs from crawling up trees they'll fall
right off the tree teflon as a chain
lube is something i've come up with for
bicycles you know only dupont makes
teflon you can use it in satellites on
fabrics or leather when's the last time
you heard about a leather raincoat
you can let your imagination run wild
it's not often that you get to make
something new in this world
okay
there's a lot that i don't understand
about that and including why it was shot
by someone who's still testing out the
zoom function on their camcorder or why
that in-cell santa giggles so menacingly
at the idea of a non-stick leather
raincoat although i will say if that's
his bar it does seem pretty easy to make
something new in the world i'll show you
leather umbrella leather flower leather
snake and leather elmo that is four
great ideas i just came up with and i'm
not even a phd in a cosby sweater and if
you are wondering where the epa was in
all this you should know they were more
than a little hamstrung here under the
1976 toxic substances control acts the
epa can require testing for chemicals
only when it's been provided evidence of
potential harm a set up which largely
allows chemical companies to regulate
themselves which is an absolutely
terrifying sequence of words right up
there with incoming face time from
geoffrey tubin nobody wants to hear that
and even when the epa has taken steps
they've been pretty limited for instance
in 2016 they issued a health advisory
for two of the biggest p files including
c8 setting an acceptable level for them
in drinking water of 70 parts per
trillion which incidentally a lot of
people still think is too high but also
crucially an epa health advisory is
non-enforceable and no one is going to
respect a rule if it's not enforced it's
like one of those signs that everyone
sees but ignores like please take one on
a candy bowl or please no sculpture
at madame two swords i'm doing
it i'm taking two fun-sized snicker bars
and then i'm gonna wax michael
buble i'm doing it it's already done get
over it
and that lacks level of oversight
combined with dumping on a scale so high
they lose track of it has had severe
consequences when epidemiologists
studied the medical history of people
who lived near a dupont plant they found
residents with high exposure to drinking
water contaminated with c8 had much
higher rates of kidney and testicular
cancers and it was even worse for the
people working inside the facilities as
this man who worked in one of dupont's
testing labs and has since been
diagnosed with ulcerative colitis and
rectal cancer can attest
people would handle that product on
their job every day
day in night out
and then when we went to 12 hour shifts
at 12 hours at a time
we heated it and breathed it
every day ken worked on a four-man team
at dupont's plant testing c8 between
1974 and 2001
of the four
he's the only one still alive
the people i loved
they died
and we were like a family
look that is clearly awful but you don't
actually even have to live in a town
where pea fires are dumped or work in a
factory that makes them to be affected
here remember pea fires last a long time
so if they sink into the groundwater or
are released into the air they can
travel and they can bio accumulate
meaning that they build up in your body
over time and that brings us to a
shocking discovery because in the 1970s
dupont and 3m started testing workers to
check the levels of pfas in their blood
and 3m wanted a control group with clean
blood so that they'd have a baseline but
as this environmental activist points
out the company quickly realized
something truly horrifying there was no
clean blood they tested kids they tested
adults they went to asia they went all
over the world and everywhere they
looked practically
they found their chemicals
in people's blood
eventually they did find some clean
blood
it turned out it was the blood that had
been taken
from army recruits and archived saved at
the start of the korean war yup it's
true in fact a cdc study has found that
c8 is now in the blood of 99.7
of americans i mean at the very least
vin diesel and i finally have something
in common every single thing about our
genetic makeup general attitude and
vocal tamber is dramatically different
but when it comes to toxic chemicals in
our blood it's potato potato my friend
or should i say my family
and while dupont may be a particularly
stark example they are far from the only
entity involved here the military uses
pfas in foam to extinguish fire so pfas
have built up around military bases and
many companies have used a lot of
p-files in a lot of their products for
instance a shoe company called wolverine
used p-files in its waterproof hush
puppies but it was only after local
reporting that residents near its
factory in belmont michigan knew to get
their water tested and for one family
the mcnaughtons the results were pretty
striking and before you watch this
remember the epa's acceptable level in
drinking water is 70 parts per trillion
they lived in their house about three
years when tobin learned she was
pregnant with their son jack
we're really excited i wanted that to go
really well so i drank eight glasses of
water a day i liked kept track i ate
really healthy
in april of 2016 jack was born he had an
immense appetite for water he was
thirsty all the time tests showed almost
2 000 parts per trillion of pfas in the
mcnaughton's water as soon as they could
tobin and seth had jack's blood tested
the results
484 000 parts per trillion
more than 100 times the national average
he's the highest level pfasts that we
know right now of any child in the
united states
he's get sick market and his vaccine
vaccinations haven't worked
wow that is incredible usually when your
child is the highest in something your
instinct is to brag about it but good
luck finding a bumper sticker with my
child has the highest level of p-files
in the united states on it nobody wants
that and look i have to tell you
wolverine says that it's moved to fix
the problem for homeowners in that area
although you should know it is just not
a simple thing to go about doing
this is
what i affectionately call megatron my
whole home filter
this right here but it goes through each
of these tanks these are full of
granulated carbon
and it goes through them in order and
then comes out this one and
is clean so every
week they come and test it
at the intake and then also
at the exit so that we know that the
water is empty of that oh great news you
did it wolverine problem solved all it
takes is a four tank system
affectionately nicknamed megatron a
spare room large enough to house it and
a weekly visit from a tank technician
for the rest of your life water problem
more like what's your problem this is a
system that works
but clearly a megatron in every home is
not a viable solution for this or indeed
any problem and maybe because of that
and definitely because of a
court-approved settlement wolverine has
since gone to the trouble and expense of
switching that woman from her tainted
well water to the municipal water supply
and yet many companies are continuing to
do the bare minimum here or even trying
to evade responsibility dupont for
instance settled a class-action lawsuit
with residents of the town where it was
dumping c8 and shortly afterward agreed
to eventually phase out using the
chemical which sounds good but there are
some significant asterisks on that
because while they did stop using c8
they simply switched to a different kind
of pfas something called gen x spinning
the manufacturer of it off into a
separate company comores now did they do
that so that any legal liability
wouldn't stick to them and instead slide
right off them like bugs on a teflon
tree who can say apparently not me
legally what i can say is that while
comores claims gen x is safer scientists
still have significant concerns about
its presence in our water supply this is
in my view more of a risk than we should
be forced to take this compound's a
member of a class of compounds
that are all thought to be able to make
people sick with cancers of various
kinds other kinds of dysfunction
we don't know the full extent of it so
with what these scientists do know we
ask them if they think the water is safe
enough to drink nope i drink tequila
straight but i won't drink tap water
well that doesn't sound good
if casual friday scientists over here
won't drink the tap water there might be
some cause for alarm and while we have
just focused on a handful of individual
pfas tonight there are hundreds if not
thousands of them so the problem is if
and when gen x is eventually found to be
harmful companies can presumably just
move on to another one then onto another
one and so on and so on and at this
point you might be thinking holy
this is absolutely terrible should i
start immediately throwing away all of
my pants well i will start with the good
news megan mccain is no longer on the
view this rock looks like cookie monster
and no you don't necessarily need to
throw away all of your pants experts say
that it's very unlikely p-files will be
released if the pans aren't overheated
or scraped now you're under slightly
more risk of exposure from clothing that
contains p-files which is unfortunately
most stain-proof or waterproof fabrics
including certain items from companies
like lululemon north face and patagonia
or indeed from food wrappers that
contain p-files which are unfortunately
used by multiple chains including some
of the packaging at starbucks
chick-fil-a and subway and all of these
companies insist that they are working
to remove pfas from their products
completely in the coming months and
years and i hope that that is true but
we have heard things like that before
and yet here we are
and it is not like it is easy to know
which products you're buying do and
don't contain p-files it's not like they
have to carry labels stating this
product contains devil's piss although
that's actually a very good idea and
they should absolutely have to do that
but the bigger issue is no matter how
responsible consumers choose to be if
the factory that makes the chemical does
not dispose of its waste properly it's
likely getting into your bloodstream
anyway which is pretty frustrating as
the activist you saw earlier points out
no one said hey you know i'm i'm good
with a little teflon chemical
in my baby's blood no one said that they
said i love these pans exactly no one
loves pan so much they'd be willing to
put poison in their babies blood well to
be honest one person does but in his
defense the pans don't stink
now
if you are worried about what the water
is like where you live you can go to
this address ewg.org pfast map and if
you don't like what you see you can
consider solutions like drinking bottled
water or using a reverse osmosis filter
but the truth is it shouldn't just be on
us as individuals because pfas should
not be in most consumer products at all
and as companies seem unlikely to all
take them out voluntarily we badly need
legislation limiting their use to only
essential items like certain medical
devices and protective clothing but not
just that we need to change the way that
we regulate p-files completely instead
of regulating them one at a time as we
do now we should do it as an entire
class of chemicals this would enable the
epa to more effectively regulate not
just the p5s already in use but
replacements like gen x when they are
introduced and in the meantime if
companies are going to keep leaning in
on the convenience of their products
without acknowledging the cost maybe we
can help them by providing their ads
with some much needed context
chemistry is the practice of magic like
abracadabra zonks and wizards all
chemistry people think of teflon and
they think of frying pans big hot plates
with smooth long sticks teflon is not
one thing it's disease sickness and it's
everywhere that's dupont magic
ta-da
it's not close to my mouth right you
know i'm self-conscious about the mouth
you know about that
did you say yes or no putting pfaz on a
surface will stop bugs crawling up trees
i'll tell you how they'll contract
ulcerative colitis and just die
in front of your eyes
thousand little
right bugs you know i'm self-conscious
you know i'm self-conscious about the
mouth and the close-up stuff and
spitting you said it's going to be a
normal shoot no focusing on
that
i put pfaz in a bicycle chain why
because i suffer from chronic insomnia
probably got it from beef ass and
they're everywhere the same chemicals
that are in me are in you and even in
your child i put something in your child
and when this stuff gets in the water
whoa that's the real bippity boppity
magic bippity boppity match bippity
boppity magic contamination levels like
you've never seen it's incredible when
was the last time you heard about a
leather raincoat giving you kidney
cancer
how you can let your imagination run
wild
mine's running right now it's not often
you get to put something toxic in the
world
[Music]
that's our show thank you so much for
watching we'll see you next week good
night
you